je m'appelle France calamba mon
entreprise acte toi action ancien donc
acte 3 à toi d'agir et je fais de
développement du talent dans mon métier
exclutif
en sport le coaching pour des affaires
donc j'accompagnais décideurs et des
managers et les chefs d'entreprise pour
qu'il puisse transformer le contrainte
opportunité pour qu'il puisse rebondir
et être meilleur là où ils veulent
avancer pour gérer l'entreprise au mieux
conduire le changement et s'épanouir
donc développeur de talent Jacques Brel
a dit l'étalon n'existe pas le talent ça
va envie de faire les choses donc
j'essaye de donner aux gens l'envie de
trouver qu'est-ce que leur fait envie de
chercher la pépite qui est dans chaque
an donc ce qui est la petite graine
qu'on peut faire pousser j'apporte l'eau
le soleil et se fait pousser les salons
quand on a en soi pour justement avoir
un management plus humain plus que le
sens pour donner aux gens envie de faire
ce qui est son sens et de faire mais
avec un vrai épanouissement pour
atteindre la haute performance